so let me briefly with that introduce
professor Bonet him seems like every
time we introduce him there's a new line
attitude is his resume so the first
thing to just say is that his research
focus is on applications of cryptography
to computer security his work includes
crypto systems with novel properties web
security security for mobile devices and
crypt analysis here at Stanford he heads
the applied cryptography groopman
co-directs the computer security lab as
well as more recently he's a co-director
and a co-founder maybe of the Center for
blockchain research he's the recipient
of numerous awards including the ACM
prize in the goyda prize and I in 2011
he received the issue award for industry
education innovation and I've already
touched on it I think professor Bonet
will touch on it as well but I just want
to emphasize this point the amount of
work he does to make his research
available to the public in addition to
the online graduate courses that he
teaches he was co-developed a self-paced
online certificate in computer security
he's created a massively popular MOOC
he's talking about doing more he's also
co-written a free graduate level
textbook on cryptography that you can
find online so these contributions are
numerous it's not just the webinar and
with that I'm going to hand over the
presentation to do professor Bonet
listen thank you thank you very much and
thanks all for joining us excited to be
here welcome to this webinar I guess
I'll talk a little bit about some of our
recent work and also welcome you to our
courses later this year so with that
let's get started so actually we're
gonna turn off the video just so you can
focus on the content and my experience
it's easier to focus on content if you
just listen to my words rather than you
see me flailing my hands so the first
thing I wanted to mention is we have a
pretty active security lab here at the
University at Stanford this is a
computer security lab as part of the
computer science department so I just
listed some of the faculty who work in
the lab so myself you're gonna hear more
about my work in a minute secure works
on measuring security on the Internet
Matea works on big data and security
Dawson works on static analysis for code
David Nazir's works on consensus
protocols and building secure systems
from insecure components there Levis
works on IP security
John Michell works on protocol design
and Mendel rosenbloom works on virtual
machines and security so there's a lot
of different angles of computer security
that are being addressed by different
faculty as you can see here my work
primarily focuses on applied
cryptography blockchains web security
and that of course expands to many
different areas of security as well so
I'll tell you a little bit about our
recent work and then I'm happy to take
questions and we can do a Q&A after I'm
really looking forward to your questions
so please go ahead and kind of submit
your questions as we go through the
material I did want to mention some of
the courses that we teach so let's see
so we kind of span all the way from from
freshman undergraduates all the way to
the graduate program so you can see that
they're kind of our core main courses on
computer security that we expect all
undergraduates and computer science to
take they're all recorded and available
to you as well we teach our intro to
cryptography class which is basically
how to use cryptography in the real
world for recently we started teaching a
brought chain technology class which is
a lot of fun to teach it's basically
kind of a combination of distributed
systems and cryptography and of course
economics and legal aspects of crypto
cryptocurrencies it's a lot of fun to
teach actually we're teaching this class
ch3 61 right now this quarter and then
we have a number of graduate courses in
cryptography and computer-security as
well great facts do you want to say
something about the graduate certificate
or do you want me to go averts sure so
we have two certificates with a graduate
certificate as professors when I pointed
out there's a core number of graduate
offerings that are available online and
so this is a certificate you can take by
I believe it's for graduate offerings
you complete all four of them and then
you earn a certificate you get Stanford
academic credit and you'll get a
Stanford transcript so it is the same
class that on-campus students are taking
and it's just you're watching the
lectures remotely and we also have a
professional certificate and we'll
circle back to this at the end there are
links to these in your console the
professional certificate is a little bit
less
rigorous it's still technical I'm a
little bit shorter and it's it's
basically self-paced online modules that
teach you the fundamentals of computer
security great okay thank you all right
so with that let's dive right in so I'm
excited to tell you about some of our
about some of our recent work so what
I'd like to cover and hopefully we'll
have enough time for this is I'd like to
start off with talking about second
factor authentication and what are
called universal second factor tokens
and some security issues with those and
ways to potentially improve security of
these second factor tokens so we'll talk
about that then I'll talk about two more
topics more briefly I'd like to tell you
a little bit about how to accelerate ml
classifications when that's being done
in the cloud and so this is kind of a
cute application of cryptography and of
course you know these days we can't give
a talk on cryptography without talking
about a little bit about block chains
and so I'll tell you a little bit about
how an approach to scaling the block
chain using a concept called an
accumulator as well as what's called the
snark so we'll discuss this at the very
end and hopefully we'll have a little
bit extra time and in that which case
there's a fourth topic I would like to
tell you about doesn't I'm just going to
talk through it without slides it's kind
of a cool way of encrypting data in the
cloud so yeah so these are kind of the
recent things we've been working on in
this past year and so let's dive right
in
alright so the first topic I'd like to
start with are the second factor
authentication tokens and how to secure
them this is a system called true to F
that we developed with a couple of our
students Emma Derman in her recording
gives along with my colleague David
Nazir's and Dominic
Rizzo who was at Google and this was
published in last last May at the I
Triple E security and privacy so if you
in case you if you want to read more
about what I'm about to say you can
always go back to the paper and and get
the full details okay
so let's get right to it so I'm sure you
all know what second factor
authentication tokens are I have a
picture of one of them here and it's
kind of remarkable but last year Google
pulled out these really powerful press
releases saying that since they've
mandated the use of these tokens
their older work devices essentially
their employees have no longer been
fished yeah this is a good protection
for our protecting long-term credentials
from phishing attacks or malware attacks
and so on and so you can see these press
releases kind of explain that google has
been very successful in getting these
deployed all across their campus and in
fact as a result they've had essentially
zero successful phishing attacks against
them this is kind of a remarkable
statistic so I just wanted to share that
fact or at least those those press
releases with you oh so let's talk a
little bit about how these u2f tokens
work and what model what's what is the
security threat that they're trying to
protect against so the problem that
we're dealing with is that when you log
into a remote system through your
browser you know you're typing in your
password into a browser but you have no
idea really maybe your browser is
infected and there's malware that's
actually stealing your password as
you're typing it in maybe you're
actually not at the right site you know
you're trying to log in to your bank but
in fact you're sitting at some phishing
site and now you're just typing in your
banking password into your fishing into
the phishing site and you've just given
away your password so the problem is
that essentially we can't really trust
passwords that are being typed into the
into the browser we really we're kind of
putting them at risk and we'd like to
protect those those passwords so second
factor authentication tokens these u2f
tokens essentially are a way to ensure
that even if the browser is infected so
this is a symbol that I'll use from out
for malware even if the browser is
infected the malware cannot steal your
long-term credential maybe we can get
you a password but the password is not
enough to log into your account and so
in addition there's this u2f token u2f
token stores a secret credential as well
and in order to log into your account
you have to use both your password and
the secret credential stored under UTF
token yeah so these each of F tokens
have a couple of security capabilities
the first one is the last thing we want
is to make these YouTube tokens make it
possible to track you across different
web sites so it's important that even
though this huge AF token presents a
credential to the
it's important that it's a different
credential for every website so you
cannot be tracked just because you're
using a u2f token so here in this
example I have down here you can see the
UTF token on the left you're trying to
login into a service and I'll use github
comm as as the classic service that
would use these EGF tokens but you can
imagine the same that you the same ugf
soakin would also be used to log you
into your bank and you want to make sure
that the bank working but github can't
tell that it's you connecting through
both locations it's just a matter of you
know interesting privacy that these
tokens provide the second property they
provide are what I call these counters
and the reason for the counter is
essentially to prevent the device from
being cloned so if the UTF token somehow
you know you leave it on your desk
somebody takes it and clones it and then
gives you the original token but now
they have a clone of your token the idea
is that they should not be able to use
the clone of the token to login as you
because the token is gonna present a
counter to every on every login that
it's a sense to the service if the
service ever sees the same counter twice
or it sees a gap in the counter sequence
that means that there are two tokens
that are being used as you and that you
know it sounds the alert to tell you
that your token has been cloned and you
have to reset your token okay so those
are kind of the security threats that
these tokens are trying to prevent
against so a provide privacy so pay you
sure note your password is not stolen
theft of your password is not sufficient
B it doesn't violate your privacy and
three it ensures that a cloning a
cloning attack will be detected so I
want to tell you a little bit more about
how this protocol actually works
how does u2f actually log you in to our
remote site and so in the UCF protocol
there are basically two two steps
actually there are three steps the first
step is to initialize the device so
let's do that so when you initialize the
device basically the device generates a
secret key and then it stores locally
but once you initialize the device there
are two steps
yeah the first step is to register the
device the token with the remote service
again github.com in this case so let's
walk through abstractly how this works
and I'm getting I'm only giving a
simplified view
the protocol does we kind of understand
the basic idea of how this protocol
works so effectively what happens is the
service will send the identity of the
service yeah github.com in this case to
your browser your browser will send back
to the device along with a certain
challenge which I won't talk about here
what the device will do then is it will
generate a service specific heat yeah so
here generates kind of a secret key
that's specific to the service you're
trying to login to and we'll send the
corresponding public key yeah so this is
the public part of the secret key or
rather maybe I should be more precise
the device well generates what's called
a secret public key pair and it will
store the secret key internally and
store and send a public key back to the
service ok so what it sends over is the
the public key that the service will use
it sends a signature indicating yes this
is a key that was really generated by
the device and then it sends over this
handle so I handle it's kind of
interesting so these devices don't have
a lot of storage on them so it's not
it's unreasonable to expect them to
store the secret keys for all the
services with which you authenticate
so instead what the device will do is
we'll go ahead and encrypt this secret
key this sk ID it will encrypt it using
its long-term secret key that sk that's
on top and then the handle basically
will contain the encrypted service
specific secret key encrypted under the
general secret key stored on the device
and you can see this handle is going to
be sent all the way back to the service
and the service will store the handle
for the device ok so the service will
get the public key the signature
indicating that this is an authentic
public key and the handle which is an
encryption encryption of the s key ID
for the service so later on so this is a
registration face yeah this is where you
register the token with the service
later on when you want to authenticate
oh by the way I should mention this
public heat is being sensitive about to
the service is different for every
service and that's the part that
prevents linking of the public heat
linking your your identity across
multiple sites ok the next thing that
happens is when you want to actually log
into a service log into github that
found for example well github will do
it was it will send its identity yeah
the github.com fact a challenge and a
handle the handle back to the device the
device will use the handle to regenerate
the service-specific secret ID and then
it sends back a signature and the
challenge saying yes this is this is me
authorizing proving that I know the
secret key and I'm actually authorizing
a login into the service using my
identity you can see that there's a
counter attached here this is the anti
cloning counter that I was mentioning to
this counter is incremented for every
login to the service so a service can
then tell if it ever sees the counter
the same counter value twice it can tell
that the device has been cloned and then
the device needs to be reset but the
point is a service will then verify that
the secret that the signature that you
see here sig ID really is a signature on
the challenge and then if so it would
allow the login to proceed okay so
that's the UTSA protocol again
simplified version of the UTSA protocol
so you see how it works the X that these
two parts one for registration and one
for authentication
okay great so now that we understand how
this how the protocol works let me just
mention that there is some problems with
this protocol and the problem in
particular is the fact that the security
model that u2f is intended to defend
against is the browser being infected
and you notice if the browser is
infected that does not let the attacker
steal the device's secret key because
the infection does not affect the device
however what's been shown is that there
are sometimes flaws in the device itself
that can end up leaking your secret key
so this is a well published publicized
example from a year or two ago where
there was a issue with how Infineon
generated its
public keys these Infineon chips were
used in some of these UTF tokens as a
result these youth to have tokens were
let's say not as secure as one would
expect so this actually caused the
massive recall of a lot of the tokens
they have to be reissued and so on yeah
so this is one example where the token
itself can go wrong and that would
compromise security of the UTF protocol
but there have been
two other examples of issues with tokens
for example the token might use weak
randomness and if it when if it uses
weak randomness the secret key that the
token uses itself is not going to be
particularly secure and again remote
attacker might be able to extract the
secret key on the device by listening to
interaction with the remote service okay
so there are all sorts of issues
security issues with the tokens and so
on would like to propose is sort of a
strengthening oh actually sorry let me
explain even how these things can
actually cause harm so the problem is
it's not just bugs under token itself in
fact you know these tokens are
manufactured in some third party
facility and in some sense the users are
expected to trust that when these
devices you know appear in their mailbox
that devices themselves can be trusted
and be trustworthy to log them in into
remote services so you may have heard
there have been some issues with supply
chain attacks and so what if the device
itself has been engineered yeah the
device has been engineered to actually
leak your secret key so for example what
happens if the devices shows up in your
mailbox you initialize it but in fact
somehow the attacker meters so that even
though you've initialized the device the
attacker will know the secret key that's
gonna live on your device and if the
attacker knows the secret key on your
device they can effectively log in as
you to any site where they also know
your password yes so we'd like to make
sure that that cannot happen it turns
out that's actually not so difficult to
defend against making sure that the
secret key on the device is unknown to
the attacker I'll show you how to do
that in a minute but it turns out even
that's not enough
right so suppose the secret key is
secure on the device there's even worse
problems that can happen so I told you
that for every service the device has to
generate a public key and then it sends
that to the service well what if the
public key is generated in such a way
where the bits of the public key leak
the devices long-term secret key right
now that's another way for you know a
rogue device to leak the secret key
that's on the device even worse what
happens if when the device generates a
signature the signature is
self leaks the long-term secret key then
let me remind you that u2f uses a
signature scheme called ECDSA ECDSA in
ECDSA there's randomness that's being
used to generate ECDSA signatures well
what if the randomness of the device
uses is such that the resulting ECDSA
signature leaks the device's secret key
again no one can tell that this is
happening but the remote server will
learn your secret key okay so these are
kind of concerns that we have about the
security of the devices in our goal of
course is to secure devices against
those types of attacks okay so that
that's where that's where we're headed
so yeah so we're not saying this is
actually going on in the world world
it's just it would be nice if as a
customer when a device appears in my
mailbox I would have some guarantees
that even if the device is malicious it
cannot read my long-term second factor
secrets okay so this is where the system
true to F comes into play that's
arguments u2f and so let me explain let
me tell you what true to F does so just
to review the basic you to have security
model says if your browser is infected
then malware on your browser cannot
steal you your your u2f long-term
secrets what true to F does is it says
yes this is great this is a wonderful
security model and as we saw it's very
successful when Google deployed it was
very successful but we can do better so
how can we do better what we'd like to
do is actually argument the security
model and say that even if the device is
malicious but the browser has not been
infected even in that case the user
should have security okay so the malware
actually lives in the device and even
though that device now is completely
compromised an attacker still will not
be able to compromise the users second
factor token yeah that's kind of our
goal so it's not replacing u2f it's
basically augmenting the security model
that u2f is designed to protect against
now one thing I'll point out is in fact
if both your browser and your tokens are
basically compromised
you know then we can't help you well you
know we give up and at that point the
attacker has
if you compromised you know both your
browser and the token there is sort of
no root of trust and we can't really
protect you from the attacker but as
long as one of them is safe and the
other one is compromised true to a flow
still provides security so how do we do
it well so there are sort of two
principles that we follow in the design
so again this is an augmentation of v2f
it's backwards compatible with us just
trying to improve the security that's a
token provides for you okay so the first
principle is what we'd like to do is
essentially every response that the
token sends back to the browser can be
verified by the browser okay so the
browser does not know the tokens secret
even though the browser doesn't know the
token secret it can verify that
everything that the token did is correct
yeah so for example when it generates an
ECDSA signature the browser should be
able to verify that that ECB signature
was generated using truly random
randomness okay that's kind of the goal
we're headed forth towards and the way
we do that by the way is using using
techniques that come from the world of
zero knowledge proof where effectively
the device can prove to the browser that
everything it did is it did correctly so
that's that's principle number one that
the device will prove it in things
correctly to the browser so as long as
the browser is honest that device cannot
cheat the second principle is there are
places where the device needs randomness
for example when the device generates
its initial secrets it needs randomness
okay and so today we basically rely on
the device to generate randomness on its
own in true to F what happens is the
browser contributes randomness to the
process so some randomness of generative
and browser some randomness is generated
on the device and the combination of the
two sources of randomness are used to
generate the secrets on the device yeah
so as long as one of them is truly
random the total result on the device
will be truly random and the interesting
thing here is the device has to prove
that it didn't just ignore the
randomness that came from the browser it
has to prove that it actually used that
randomness okay and again this goes into
the realm of zero knowledge proof swear
it proves that it generated is public
key correctly using the random
the browser without revealing the secret
key to the actual browser so how do we
do it
well so there are three cryptographic
tools that are that we employ here yeah
so again I'm gonna keep this at a high
level so I'll walk through these like
you know they're very high level if
somebody's interested at the end that
can maybe go into a bit more detail but
for now I'll just describe these at a
high level so the first step to remember
is the device had to generate a secret
key during the initialization time we'd
like to make sure that secret key is
well have high entropy and no one
outside of the device will know what
that's in fakirs so well we do that as
again like I mentioned we use entropy
that's generated both on the token and
on the browser those that entropy that
joined entropy is used to generate the
device as long term secrets and then the
device proves that it actually used that
long term secret yes again this is using
the concept of zero knowledge proof
where I can prove to you the device can
prove to the browser that they did
things correctly without actually
revealing any of its secrets to the
browser by the way I have to say as your
nose proofs are a truly fascinating
fascinating area of cryptography it's
kind of a remarkable fact that anything
that you can do anything you can prove
you can actually prove in zero knowledge
and this is something that should we
just discuss in our crypto class and
quite a bit of depth in that this is
kind of become a fairly important tool
especially in the world of block chains
the world of zero knowledge proof allows
you to do private transactions on a
public blockchain yeah so it's quite
fascinating that this tool that's been
developing in the crypto world for 20 to
30 years now has become very practical
and very widely needed in the world of
block chains yeah but that's only the
first part so collaboration is the first
part the second part is remember when we
do that when we register a device with a
particular website we have to we have to
generate a public key this PK ID that's
specific to the website
okay so we'd like to make sure that the
public key is random so you cannot be
tracked at the same time it needs to be
verifiable by the bra
so here we have a cryptographic
mechanism we call a verifiable I didn't
family but really what it does is it's a
way for the device to generate a unique
public key per service derived from its
long-term secret key that the browser
can verify was generated correctly again
the browser doesn't know the secret key
but it can verify that this PK ID this
service specific public key was
generated correctly and is truly random
yeah so that we do on the browser so
that's the second step that's during
registration and finally during during
vloggin during authentication we have to
make sure that the ECDSA signature is
generated correctly and again we use
something similar to collaborate
collaborative key generation to make
sure that the ECDSA signature will
generate corrected okay so we put these
three components together this the
interesting thing here is that this
forces changes on the device
yeah so you have two argument the design
of the device you have two arguments the
browser so we have a browser extension
that sits in your browser and interact
with the device using the tools that we
just described here interestingly the
service need does not need to change at
all so github.com doesn't change at all
these are really only client-side
changes which of course makes it easier
to deploy yeah so this is kind of idea
so the goal here is to argument the Utah
security model to provide security also
against a malicious device so you know
of course we'd like to implement an
experiment with things so so we
implemented this this is how you can see
here this was implemented on a tests
development device so you can see the
USB and the right of the picture you can
see the USB token that plugs in but this
is a development device obviously you
can take this and shrink it in to just a
regular form factor for a YouTube token
but for us you know development device
was sufficient just to demonstrate that
this works and so you can see
performance numbers here it's
effectively let's see the top row shows
you I won't go into too much detail here
I'll just tell you the top row shows
that during registration time
registration takes 234 milliseconds as a
purse of 204 milliseconds
so you add 30 milliseconds to
registration time to do all this extra
work to randomize and verify so 30
milliseconds is not something that the
ordinary user will notice so seems quite
reasonable
during authentication time you can see
it goes up from 171 from 147 to 171 so
again we're adding roughly 30
milliseconds to us an occasion again not
something that a typical user will
notice so what this says is essentially
using the existing hardware on u2f
tokens just by changing the software on
the tokens and embedding an extension in
the browser you can actually provide
security against malicious token
basically for free yet the user will not
notice any of these changes and that
will strengthen the system okay so we
hope this will actually get deployed
adopted it demonstrate that using these
kind of more advanced cryptographic
schemes we can achieve better security
oh good so yeah I guess I have a link to
the paper here in case you're interested
in learning more about how this works
yeah so it's basically a way to make you
to have tokens resistant to these
backdoors but we hope that these things
will actually get adopted by the YouTube
standards so we'll see we'll see if that
happens that we can all have stronger
u2f tokens one thing that I'd love to
talk a little bit about the future here
in that I imagine many of you actually
use u2f tokens today and many of you are
probably annoyed that you have to
sacrifice USB ports for the token right
you put the youth token into the USB
port and then you can't use the support
anymore well so I'm hoping I'm hoping
this is coming in in the short term
where these second factor authentication
tokens will actually be built into our
laptops and built into our phones so all
we would have to do is just you know use
the say the MacBooks fingerprint reader
and that's how we authenticate the u2f
token built into our laptop to
authenticate ourselves beyond the
password the interesting thing is even
if we live in a world where u2f is
embedded in our laptops and in our
phones even then we're still we still
need you to have tokens to be you know
standalone devices because we need them
for backup right if somebody steals our
laptop
we'd still like to have some
you two have token that we can go back
to maybe we stored in a safe somewhere
maybe we store it in our drawer at home
we still have to have an youtube's token
that we can go back to and we login
andrea fennec 8 once we buy a new laptop
and so these tokens are still going to
be with us and so we still need to
implement something like a true 2f to
protect us from tokens that we might not
fully trust so that's interesting the
other point I'd like to make is that
once we have u2f tokens embedded into
our laptops and phones it's interesting
that exactly the same technology can be
used for other things as well so in
particular it's it's fascinating that
the whole true 2f technology what I just
described batik using an untrusted token
to login on your behalf that exact set
of tools could also be used to support a
crypto currency or crypto wallets in our
phones and our laptops if you are so
inclined to do so what do I mean by that
this approach to collab collab
collaborative key generation that the
wallet will use to generate its public
key where funds will be deposited again
you'd like that to be done
collaboratively between the laptop and a
security token this verifiable address
generation well that's not something
that's actually done in crypto wallets
as well and we'd like that to be
verifiable as well and so that could
also be used for crypto wallets and
finally you'd like your ACC DAC
signatures that are used in many
blockchain projects you would like those
to be properly generated and not leaked
your secret Keys so again that would
also be done in a collaboration between
a token and a browser and so if you were
so inclined to run a wallet and store it
in your laptop everything that I talked
about applies equally well also to quark
the wallet so it's interesting where you
work on one thing for authentication and
it turns out to be applicable to a
completely different and unrelated area
yeah so that's that was kind of a
coincidence that's we were we were happy
that that happened ok good that's all I
wanted to say about u2f tokens hope you
guys have some questions I'm happy to
discuss this in more detail later on but
I want to switch gears now and talk
about something completely different
ok so now for something completely
different
so the next thing I'd like to talk about
is something that we did a few months
ago on a way to do a way to outsource
machine learning classification to the
cloud so this is a system called Solomon
was developed with my PhD students
Florian tremor and again the paper
appeared recently in AI CLR okay let me
explain what the problem is so we're
shifting here to something completely
different but again I'd like you to know
that these tools exist and I hope these
tools will be useful to you in your in
your job ok so what is the problem we're
trying to address you so so here's the
here's a very common situation imagine
you have the task of classifying images
I don't know maybe you have a database
of thousands of images and you'd like to
run a machine learning classification
model on those images so you've already
built your model you just like to run it
on those images so very often what
people do is they will upload the model
to the cloud the cloud has you know
racks of GPUs that are vacation so you
can run your model on the thousands of
images that you have using the clouds of
GPUs and get the results quickly yes you
can see the input is X the output is y
you know everybody's happy the cloud
generates the results quickly because it
has all the GPUs maybe you don't have
the GPUs and so you allow that you know
you you leverage the clouds hardware and
you get classification done quickly
there's only one problem with this
picture
which is well you know not everybody
fully trusts the cloud and so the
question is can see in this picture
basically you have to upload your model
to the cloud you have to upload all your
data to the cloud the question is can we
do any better yeah so what we'd like to
do is we'd like to a make sure that we
have integrity in other words the cloud
the results we get back from the clouds
are correct right so we can trust that
the cloud correct clear and exact
classification algorithm we'd like to
have privacy right so that the cloud
can't actually see the data that we're
trying to classify and we might also
like to have a model privacy where the
cloud doesn't even learn the model that
we're using so a very common approach
for doing that this is again this is a
very standard concern in industry you
know we're outsourcing all of our crown
jewels for the cloud we'd like to have
some
better control of what the cloud does
with all this data so very common or at
least an approach that's up-and-coming
is well let's try to let's try to limit
what cloud users can see quite
administrators can see by using Hardware
anklets okay so imagine what we do is we
put everything in an in clave so what's
an in clave I imagine I get many of you
have heard for example of interests us
so that's a standard and clave
architecture where the idea is that
inside the processor you can separate
sort of create and then claim that the
code running in the in clave and the
data that's that the code operates on
are sort of tamper proof so the outside
world can't see the beta and cannot
modify the data and cannot modify the
code and so this allows you basically to
encrypt your model and only decrypt it
inside of the enclaves encrypt your data
only decrypt the data inside of the in
clave run the classification job inside
of the in clave and send the results
encrypted back to the client the client
will decrypt and get the results in the
clear so by doing this everything in the
cloud is encrypted except where it's
inside of a hardware and clave at which
point cloud administrators can't
actually see the model they can't see
the data and they can't interfere with
the classification process there's only
one problem with this picture the cloud
invested all this money in building a
GPU infrastructure and now that we get
everything inside of an Intel and clave
the GPU infrastructure is standing there
is sitting there completely item we
can't use it anymore because everything
has to run inside of the anklet by the
way I wanted to mention that Intel SGX
is only one anklet architecture there
are many other in clave architectures
available MD has an arcane clave
architecture risk 5 has an antelope
architecture and so these enclaves are
gonna be all around us they're gonna be
all available and we might as well
we might as well put them to use and
this is one example that we'd like what
we'd like to put them to use but you can
see the problem GPUs don't have any
waves yes and so we'd like to take
advantage of untrusted GPU even though
everything is operating inside of an
anklet so
with this picture we have security but
now we've lost performance so we have a
trade-off here between security and
performance and these kind of trade-offs
is exactly where cryptography can come
in and help and so what slalom does is
effectively a cryptographic protocol
between the enclaves and the GPU rack
that allows the GPU to speed up the
classification process without looking
at the data in the clear and without
being able to tamper with the results
okay so let me explain what I mean by
that so the classification process is
essentially running through layer of a
neural net every layer of a neural net
is some sort of a linear process that's
a kind of a very skewed matrix vector
product so what we can do is effectively
do everything inside of the end clave
where things run slowly but the matrix
vector products that are done at a
different layer of the neural nets those
were gonna outsource to the GPU but
we're gonna do it in such a way that the
data being outsourced to the GPU is is
encrypted so the GPU cannot see the data
in the clear and the results that come
back from the GPU can be verified
quickly by the anklet okay so we're not
relying on the end on the GPUs for
integrity and the GPU itself does not
see the data in the clip the one issue
here is a for this to work the model the
GPU does need to know what the model is
okay so in fact we install them the
model doesn't to be public so we don't
achieve model privacy but we do achieve
integrity and privacy okay so this is
Rolla I hope this is relevant to things
you're trying to do in your own
organizations and if this is something
you're interested in you know please
come talk to us we'd be very happy to
help deploy this in the real world so
let me tell you just in terms of
performance what are we achieved by
doing this and so the experiments we did
we're using Intel SGX and you know an
NVIDIA GPU and the comparison here is
comparing a set effectively slalom which
uses the SGX and clave along with the
GPU but we compare that just to doing
everything instead of the in clave
without using a GPU which is what you
would need to do today if you were gonna
do things securely and so we have here
three examples of we were lets you know
vgg
Burnett and ResNet there's a standard
image classification neural nets and you
can see the bar on the left means that
we just use following for integrity so
we just want to make sure that GPUs are
giving us the right results back but we
don't care about care about privacy you
can see we're getting like an order of
magnitude speed-up over doing everything
inside of the in clave and the bar on
the right shows if we do integrity and
privacy you can see ah this is supposed
to be like 10 the first number is
supposed to be a 10 and not one yeah so
we're still getting like an order of
magnitude improvement over doing
everything in the envy anklet somehow
the one became this was supposed to be a
10 another one so you can see that these
kind of methods really do speed things
up overdoing everything instead of an N
claim and so again I hope this is
something that you can put to use and
we'd be more than happy to help make it
real one thing that I wanted to point
out is security is never ever ever free
and so if you compare this to doing
things in securely that is doing
everything on the GPU so that there's no
data privacy in no data integrity things
are much faster
so even slalom even though we're able to
outsource a lot to the GPU Stowell is
still slower than doing everything on
the GPU so that's my brief description
of slalom and now we're gonna move on to
yet another topic yeah so I want to tell
you a little bit about blockchains I
guess these days we can't give a
cryptography talk and not talk about
block chains so let me tell you about we
have many many different cryptographic
blockchain projects that we're doing you
know it's amazing that blockchain is an
incredible consumer of advanced
cryptographic techniques so we're having
a lot of fun designing cryptographic
techniques they can then be used by a
blockchain projects here I want to tell
you about just one of those one of those
projects it has to do with scaling the
blockchain which I gave it is something
that I think many of you it's a tool
that many of you should know about so
let me explain how this works so first
of all let me remind you how the block
chains how block chains work today so
this is how this is the typical
picture for a public blockchain so
Bitcoin etherium and many many others
effectively you know we have a set of
miners that create blocks on the
blockchain and
we have a set of users that create
transactions the way transactions are
submitted to the blockchain today is
effectively by the users sending all
their transactions to the miners the
miners then verify all these
transactions and the transactions get
posted onto the block effectively this
is kind of how things works it's not so
exactly how things work but you can
think of it abstractly as though that's
what's happening yeah so everybody
verifies the transactions and then those
transactions get get posted so you look
at this picture and you say well this is
looks a little odd why is everybody very
thing verifying the transaction seems
like it's enough that just one person
would verify the transaction and then
everybody else potentially would trust
that one person well today we can't do
that because we don't have a single we
don't want to have a single point of
trust so this approach of course is
expensive and creates a lot of
replicated work so the question is can
we do better
yeah and we do better and the answer is
we can again using crypto magic okay so
let me talk a little bit about this
crypto magic that's used here and this
is a beautiful beautiful idea it's due
to Barry white hat from last year it's a
project called roll-up and the idea here
is to have basically one server called
the roll-up server that's gonna verify
all the transactions so here the picture
now is all the transactions will get
sent to this roll-up server however if
the roll-up server is the one that
verifies the transactions by the way
when I say verify transactions what I
mean is that you know there are and
money's not being created money's not
being lost there's enough balance to
cover transactions by payers and so on
and so forth basically the rules of the
blockchain are being followed
so the roll-up server will verify that
all the transactions are valid but how
are the miners gonna trust that that was
done correctly and the answer is the
roll-up server will verify the
transactions and produce what's called a
short cryptographic proof that that
verification was done correctly okay so
this is done using an absolutely magical
cryptographic tool called a stark the
snart stands for succinct
non-interactive arguments of knowledge
you know it's a complicated sentence but
what it does fundamentally is not
difficult to explain effectively it's a
way to
this proof pie is a snark that proves
that a rollup server did verification
correctly and this proof pie is short
and is very easy for the miners to
verify yeah so the roll-up server does
all the work the miners can very quickly
verify that that proof is correct okay
so what happens next is this proof gets
sent you know so a summary of the
transaction plus the proof get sent to
the miners now the miners just verify
the proof and that is very easy to do
yeah if you like a little bit of math
here if the time to generate to verify
the transaction is T the time to verify
the proof is logarithmic in T yeah so
effectively it's an exponential speed-up
in terms of the work that the miners
need to do yeah we went from linear time
to verify all the transaction
transactions to logarithmic time to just
verify the proof yeah this is the
magical Snorks and that that's what the
roll observer does okay so in effect if
you batch a thousand transactions
together into one proof effectively this
is a thousand x reduction in the amount
of work that the blockiness to do so
it's kind of an amazing way to scale to
scale the blockchain and I can tell you
there are actually a number of projects
on route now on route now to deploy this
so that we'll have this running soon
okay so so this is beautiful beautiful
beautiful idea there's one problem and
the problem is generating the snark
proof generating the proof pie is kind
of expensive expensive in terms of
computing time so the roll-up server
effectively would have to use lots and
lots of GPUs to generate this proof pie
in a reasonable amount of time so that
the transactions along with the proof
can be posted to the blockchain without
too much delay right if the if the
roll-up server took 24 hours to generate
the proof that would be impractical
right because a transaction will get
posted to the role of server but it
would only appear on the blockchain 24
hours later where we'd like to have it
appear on the blockchain right away so
we'd like to have these proofs be as
fast and as cheap as possible to
generate and that's basically where our
work comes in so we have a way to speed
up these proof generate this proof
generation by an order of magnitude over
over
what warm-up does specifically that
cryptographic tool we use is what's
called an accumulator I don't think I'm
gonna have time to explain what an
accumulator is but it's one of these
things that we discuss in the crypto
class so if you want to learn more you
can either read our paper or you know
again we're very happy to discuss these
things in the class so these are gonna
kind of very pretty cryptographic ideas
that I can can again can be used to
scale up things like a cryptographic
blockchain but potentially they could be
useful in other scenarios as well all
right so I was thinking of telling you
about one more topic but I see that
we're at time now so maybe I'll just
mention it as a teaser and if somebody's
interested I can answer this I can talk
about it in the Q&A session especially
it's a way to updates to do key rotation
in the cloud more efficiently than what
we can do today so I can either talk
about that a future semmen webinar or at
the happy good points to our papers that
describe this but I think with that I'm
gonna stop I hope you enjoyed this short
presentation it's a quick quick preview
of things that we've talked about and
kind of the tools that are that are used
in the work that I described are things
that we described in our various
cryptography classes so if you're if you
want to learn more I'd be you know I'd
be thrilled and happy to see you or in
any of our classes so I will stop here
and it over back to you thank you thank
you Dan so with that I'm going to turn
it over to some Q&A with Professor Bonet
so and then maybe coming to some general
questions so the first place to start
would be the the the two the two at the
u2f tokens so a couple questions came in
regard to compromised hardware so just
in general you said that if the hardware
and the browser is both compromised then
you're at a lot what do you see as the
future in terms of supply chain attacks
and protecting hardware and verifying
that hardware is not affected when it
comes sort of brand-new I think that's a
really wonderful wonderful topic and
it's a wonderful topic actually for
future research as well so you probably
have heard that there have been supply
chain attacks on motherboards where
extra chips were plan
I'm on the motherboard and opened up a
back door if those had been deployed and
so it's pretty clear that supply chain
attacks on coupon computing hardware in
general is coming and we need to do
something about this we will focus here
specifically a supply chain attacks on
one type of hardware namely the UTF
token but I think the principles we
developed here would apply more
generally right so the principle is
everything that the hardware does needs
to be verified by a different piece of
hardware yes and so that that principle
I think can take us a long way although
there's a lot of research that needs to
be done to make sure this this actually
is possible and works so in particular
if we're dealing with with hardware that
manages secrets it's much harder to have
another piece of hardware verify that
the the first Hardware is doing its job
correctly but that's where this this the
world of zero knowledge will step in
yeah you can prove that you did things
correctly without revealing anything
about the secrets that are on the
hardware if the hardware doesn't manage
any secrets you know then there's a then
there's a there's a paradigm called in
various programming where you basically
kind of run multiple copies of of the
code potentially on different pieces of
hardware and you compare those one next
to the other so this is all very
expensive yeah obviously running you
know triplicate in your data center and
running everything three times it's
super expensive but you know if we can't
trust the supply chain those are the
type of steps that would have to be
taken so you know this is gonna think
it's a big it I think it's a beginning
of a long long line of research what's
the best way to defend against malicious
hardware and I think we're only the
beginning of this I wish I had the full
answer here but there's a lot more
research that's needed here and yeah I
mean that's the sort of things that we'd
love to work on and you'd mentioned sort
of building in the the token into the
hardware itself into the computer into
the laptop and you know there are other
ways to do this could you use a
Bluetooth enabled sort of Authenticator
call yeah a lot of these a lot of these
you to focus today are already Bluetooth
enabled or not necessarily bluetooth
it's a other other
they're unable to learn tooken itself
and that's needed because of phones
right phones don't have USB ports so if
you're gonna usually you do have token
with your phone is that they have to
communicate over some wireless protocol
and so these u2f tokens already supports
support wireless protocols and you
mentioned that they have limited storage
capacity is there an opportunity for
them to be infected you know when you're
plugging into an effective machine is
there a way for information to be stored
in the uqf token to then compromise it
at that point as well
well again potentially these etf tokens
are designed to effectively not be
compromised by a machine they're plugged
into but of course you know hardware and
software is hardware and software that
it might happen although presumably
these devices if they're well designed
use devices are simple enough that
they're not going to be affected by
malware running on the laptop there is
concern about the other way around
right there's concern that you order a
u2f token it appears in your mail box
you plug it into your laptop and the u2f
token actually has malware on it and it
might infect your laptop that way so
there is some there's quite a bit of
concern about that we basically try to
make sure that the u2f token cannot leak
your second factor secrets but the ugf
token might just infect your machine out
right right and that is again something
that's that's a matter of operating
system security where the operating
system on your laptop needs to generally
defend itself against token plugged into
USB ports and that's just a matter of
time I mean things get things get locked
down over time we're not there yet you
know today if you find a USB token in
the parking lot the last thing you want
to do is plug it into your laptop yeah
the best thing to do is give it the
lasting thumb I suppose and so so we're
not there yet we still are not at the
point where we can plug on trust the
devices in our laptop and assume things
will just work but hopefully operating
systems will get to the point where this
is this is possible given time I want to
move on in the next one so solemn and my
pronouncing yes yes so just a couple
questions and now this is where it's
hitting against my knowledge so there's
a question saying that there are a
number of works on private in
but not a lot on private training can
you comment on this what are some
limitations on private training that we
need actually there's a there's a fair
amount of work on private training this
falls into an area called federated
learning and so this is something that
you can that you know our audience can
google and and read some papers about
this so there are some beautiful
examples of private data sets that you
would like to train on
but those data sets can never be
combined into a single location so there
are protocols for doing federated
learning the results today are actually
obviously they're not as accurate as if
you do centralized learning but this is
possible by the way I should say another
aspect of privacy during training time
is where you'd like to train and make
sure that the model that you produce at
the end of the training process doesn't
leak the training data yeah and there's
a huge amount of work on that so this is
another aspect of private training and
this is where differential privacy
techniques come into play there's
actually again a fair amount of work on
this lots of very very pretty ideas and
how to make sure that the model does not
leak the training data that I'd be happy
to go into more detail but that actually
is a topic for a whole other webinar
because this is a you know privacy and
security of training is like a pretty
big topic in its own right kind of way I
mean maybe I'll mention one more
sentence there you know there have also
been beautiful attacks very interesting
attacks on the training process we're
literally corrupting 1 beta item out of
a huge dataset is enough to completely
poison the dating process it's sorry the
training process it's a quite a
remarkable remarkable result there and
so that could be a topic you know
security machine learning is a huge area
this actually goes by the name of
adversarial machine learning and it's
all about how do we attack and defend
the training day that the training
process as well as the classic
classification process we could easily
do a whole webinar just on that that's a
huge huge area now that's great I'm
making a note then let's move on to
block train sure so locked you mention
this I think with the zero knowledge
proof
so the question is right when you're
publishing something to the blockchain
it's public is currently open to
everyone how do you do that in a way
that's encrypted or that's private oh
you're asking this question about how do
you run private transactions in a pub
yeah yeah so generally I love that
question so that's generally kind of the
area where where's your NAS proof shine
yeah so the idea there is instead of
putting your transaction data on the
blocking what you actually put on the
blockchain is a commitment to your
transaction data you can think of it as
sort of an encryption of the blockchain
sorry encryption of your transaction but
where there is never need to decrypt
yeah so you put a commitment of your
transaction and the blockchain that
leaks nothing about your actual
transaction and then what you do is you
you provide in addition to the
commitment you provide us your knowledge
proof saying that this transaction is
valid whatever is committed is in fact a
valid transaction relative to the
current state of the blotching yeah so
this allows the blockchain to sort of be
universally or publicly verifiable
everybody can verify that transactions
are correct so money's not being created
money is not being lost and the rules
are being followed but they learn
nothing about the content of the
transaction okay so this is this is like
a killer app for for zero knowledge
proof systems you know again I wish I
could tell you more about that in this
short webinar
it's a again a wonderful wonderful area
you know it's we you know our blockchain
class we're literally just doing this
right now
so we just devoted three weeks just to
explain how these zero knowledge groups
work and how they can be used to do
public transit private transactions and
a public blockchain it's not something
that I can kind of explain the idea but
it's not something that I can explain in
one minute it's it's a deeper concept to
explain and for that you know I hope I
really hope to see you in our classes
where we go into much more depth about
this so one one concept of the
blockchain is that you have the data
distributed to it so that if one server
is corrupted it doesn't necessarily
krupp the others does this and I may be
misunderstanding this so by taking the
roll-up server approach are you
centralizing back the information oh so
we're not we're not yes that's the whole
point even if the roll-ups
the road server is not a trusted server
even if the roll-up service cross it
cannot issue fake transactions right
because for every transaction that it
produces it has to produce a proof that
that transaction is valid so this is
this is really important to understand
the roll-up server is a compute server
it does not do anything trusted
everything that it does is publicly
verifiable that's the whole point of the
role of server and when we will keep
interested in as basically how do we
speed that up how do we make it easier
to produce these these books are there
any current deployed block chains using
a rollup server that's your world
so in fact roll-up is being it's a
little scholar layer to mechanism so
it's being implemented on top of the
etherium blockchain and there are a
number of projects actually on their way
to to make this available you'll see you
know later this year or maybe early next
year you'll see some launches of these
projects running great we didn't work
over time so I wanted respectful you
know it's time just to quick last
questions the first one because everyone
was asking this any update on crypto to
another excellent question yeah so I
guess crypto one is is a MOOC on
cryptography and I promise to have a
more advanced look it's called crypto 2
so that is coming yes I'm working on it
I promise however I am also working on a
textbook in cryptography this it's a
freely available textbook available to
anybody it's available at crypto book
that u.s. free textbook and as soon as
the textbook is finished crypto to will
launch basically everything in crypto 2
is based on what's in the textbook so I
want to finish the textbook first and
then we will do then I will do crypto
too so hopefully it's another year away
we're getting there but yeah yeah crypto
to is high on my priority list so I hope
not to disappoint well I'm glad that we
got a lot of questions about it so I
guess the last thing to ask is we sign
office when you're looking at the
horizon of cryptography and
computer-security what are you most
excited or scared of in the next let's
say four years oh my god that's a lot of
topics so I think I just heard machine
learning is is a pretty exciting area
this is where effectively you you know
the community shows that machine
learning algorithms work fantastically
well on random data they don't work so
well on adversarial data and
how to make them robust this is a big
big area for computer security obviously
quantum computing is something that we
all are interested in so quantum
computers as you know break a lot of the
crypto that's deployed today and the
question is what is the best
cryptography to move to so there are a
couple of avenues to explore and so
that's actually being actively worked on
I guess I promised to talk about quantum
computing but we will do that in a
future webinar and yeah those I think
those are and I first and of course the
blockchain generates a lot of
interesting cryptographic questions so
that's another fun really fun area to
work in perfect well I want to thank you
so much professor Bernette for your time
today and the excellent presentation and
we appreciate everyone who joined us
remotely and we look forward to future
webinars we already have a couple topics
it sounds like yeah thank you very much
everybody and thanks for joining us
you